you uh
get everything set up
just kind of a couple works on learning
in dynamic general some games
um
and the kind of underlying question is
just can simple algorithms even converge
in these kind of complicated settings
and so i'm going to start you know very
very high level with this kind of
obvious interrupt like observation by
now that we're increasingly interacting
with learning algorithms either
knowingly or unknowingly every single
day so you know when we're ordering
something on amazon or reading the new
yorker caption on the on the cartoons um
there's some kind of algorithm running
in learning algorithm running in the
background
um but as these algorithms are deployed
into the real world where they actually
have to interact with other algorithms
and other people things can go wrong and
sometimes
um things can go wrong in kind of a very
big way um so this is kind of an example
that i think a lot of us are familiar
with which is
that a number of
um
flash crashes in financial markets have
actually been attributed to the
concerned decision-making of a large
number of high-frequency trading
algorithms uh which are all making
decisions and you know at such high
speeds and you know so so quickly that
has led to kind of instabilities in the
market which is up to these crashes
um and so i could go on and on with kind
of negative examples but the
the real takeaway is that machine
learning algorithms are increasingly
being used and you know what's known as
for what i think of as societal skill
systems um and then and as they're kind
of
deployed into these systems their
decisions can actually have wide ranging
consequences um
and
you know i wanna to think about why our
algorithms are failing in this way i
kind of want to go back to what is
really the traditional machine learning
paradigm that we we all learn of a lot
which is that you have a single
algorithm in an isolated environment
taking data and making decisions um and
basically just you know fulfill this
feedback loop here and and importantly
the the environment is static and it's
not moving
um and the data is all iid and it's kind
of a nice perfect world um but we know
the real world that we're actually using
these algorithms isn't anything remotely
close to that and it's actually kind of
more like this
where you have decision making
algorithms taking in data and making
decisions in uncertain dynamic
environments that are evolving over time
and these algorithms are interacting not
just with people
but with other algorithms which also
might have their own utility functions
in mind
and so you know this is kind of the
picture that i'm trying to make sense of
in in the two works
that i'll be talking about today
so um
today i'm going to present kind of two
two works the first is as dylan
mentioned um just some
negative results for multi-agent
reinforced learning algorithms in
general some games
um and then in the second part i'll talk
about you know really quickly some
really recent work on decentralized
bandit learning um in in matching
markets
um and so i'll dive in on this first
line of work and this is joint work with
lillian ratliff at the university of
washington mike jordan here and
shankarachashi who's also here
um
so i'm gonna start you know with this
slide here which is just you know a lot
of the successes of reinforcement
learning in in recent years you know
deep mind playing
um i think that's captured on flag from
pixels or playing you know starcraft um
or this work from open air playing you
know learning to cooperate and so on um
a lot of those successes of
reinforcement if we look under the hood
are actually
multi-agent reinforcement algorithms and
in fact they're all multi-agent kind of
policy grading algorithms so these are
just the underlying algorithms you know
they're all kind of fancy words for
trying to estimate or construct a policy
grading or an estimate of the gradient
of you know each individual player
um and so you know in in
the the question that came to mind was
really do multi-agent policy gradients
even converge in in the simplest games
um and in particular the simplest
continuous action continues space games
um so that's going to be the the
question that we're going to ask in the
first part of this talk
and so to answer this we're going to
analyze multi-agent policy-grade
algorithms in this class of games known
as linear quadratic games so for those
of you who are familiar with the lqr
problem from from control
this is kind of the you know the simple
the simplest multi-agent kind of
generalization of that problem and the
underlying thinking here is that linear
dynamics linear policies and quadratic
costs should in some sense be the
simplest setting for continuous action
states based multi-agent um rl
okay so just to give you some you know
some background on what an n player
linear quadratic game is
we basically have a shared discrete time
dynamical system um where every player
each of the end players is going to have
their own input to this dynamic system
and then the initial stage is going to
be you know randomly distributed
according to some some initial
distribution
um every player in this game is going to
have a quadratic loss function they want
to minimize
which basically has the form here where
you have some quadratic cost on on on
the state and some quadratic costs on
the amount of control effort that each
individual player is putting in
and we're going to assume just for
simplicity that each player is going to
optimize over the space of linearly
linear feedback policies
um so just you know just to
point out where everyone gets coupled in
this game is really through the state
right so everyone is
you know the losses aren't explicitly
depending on on the other player's
actions but they're all kind of
depending on each other through the
evolution of the dynamical system
great
um so this is kind of the general setup
for an end player learning quadratic
game you can see um it's it's a general
sum because every player actually kind
of wants to stabilize the system um
in in in this problem um but they all
have different kind of costs here
great so the natural solution concept in
these type of games um is that of a
global nash equilibrium and feedback
policies which is just saying that you
know no player has an incentive to
unilaterally deviate from these points
um and we make the following assumptions
which are just basically to guarantee
that a nash equilibrium exists
and the nice thing in that is that we
actually have a
an algorithm from kind of classic
control to actually find a nash
equilibrium under these conditions
which is known as kind of ricotti
coupled ricci equations using
a technique known as lyapunov iterations
um
so yeah so now i'll go into just some
results on just the general optimization
landscape of these games
um so what we can show is that this is a
non-combat status games um so just you
know as the outdoor film is
we just inherited that that's kind of
very simple um but kind of a nice
property here is that all critical
points of grading that your policy
gradient have to be growing
so you actually have no spurious
equilibrium
which is which is nice
and so in the third point in the model
each player is updating their current
policy using their policy group yeah and
we're going to assume it's deterministic
and they can calculate this policy
grading explicitly and what we what we
see when players do this is that we get
kind of these surprising behaviors you
know they're converting to these limits
um and so you know a lot of us in this
room are used to seeing limited cycles
and game dynamics so there's been very
surprising um but this is a very
different type of limit cycle than
the types that emerge um in zero-sum
games in particular because the time
average here is not the nash equilibrium
okay so i'm just averaging i'm not
actually going to solve this problem
uh and so you know in this workflow we
will be answered you know why do
possibilities fail to convert some
actions
to mention in the simulation and
learning automation works yeah and how
about two players
and two
[Music]
what structure is it
that is
so this there's no kind of they're not
optimizing over kind of
distributions or anything like this so
um because
they're not necessarily optimizing i
mean there's
it's not clear what a
mixed strategy is on this on this set
continuum
right that's right
uh
okay so you know the what what we're
looking at there that we will see is
that um an n player linear quadratic
games nash equilibria can actually be
strict saddle points of the policy
gradient dynamics so these are points
where the jacobian of these dynamics has
at least one eigenvalue with a negative
real part
um
and you know this is kind of interesting
because it tells you that instability
here is a result not just of poor
discretization like in zero-sum games
but it's actually something inherent
about that about that nash equilibrium
and so what what that means is that um
nash equilibria are strictly unstable
for also proximal point and extra
gradient type algorithms uh in these
games so we really have to come up with
a kind of whole new flavor of algorithm
for hoping to solve these games
um so the takeaway here is that unlike
in the regular lqr setting or in zero
some lq games policy grading algorithms
just have kind of no guarantees of even
local convergence to nash equilibrium
okay um and so you know the natural
question is how often are natural
equilibrium actually saddle points of
these dynamics um is that just kind of
an edge case is that pretty common um
and so we kind of ran some experiments
to see so you know this is basically the
experimental setup what we did is we
just look at two player lq games and r2
fix one player randomized all of the
matrices for the other one and just to
see
and so what we saw is that you know
um in up to basically like one in four
sometimes sometimes zero
um the nash equilibria of the game that
we could find were saddle points of
these gradient dynamics
so that means even if you initialize an
arbitrarily small ball like kind of
uniformly in an arbitrarily small ball
around the nash equilibrium you would
diverge
um
does this happen with symmetric games
have you simulated that i don't need to
know that exactly exactly that's a good
case
so
yeah so that kind of gets me to the end
of the first part of the talk which is
on these policy grading algorithms and
two games and so the takeaway is just
that they have no guarantees of
convergence and compared to actually
just in randomly sampling lq games up to
25 percent of them you know policy
gradients
yes
so
my main question is the following
the time average of that thing yeah when
it does not converge yeah
what do you understand that states
yeah i i don't um and just
it's it's actually i mean in general
limit the time average of limit cycles
doesn't actually have to be meaningful
or an equilibrium at all um that's just
in zero-sum games that happens at least
my intuitions it happens because it's a
failure of discrimination that you're
seeing so here it's not a failure of
discrimination it's just that these are
really unstable
yeah and so you just have limited cycles
um
yeah so i'm a bit confused about it so
you said that national delivery might
not exist yeah so it could be that in 25
percent of the games there's no nash
computer excuse me so this 25 of games
have not matched and it's unstable okay
so out of the full distribution how many
of these games have enough
okay so
in the second part of the book um we're
going to talk about some work on
decentralized and banded learning in
natural markets and this is
[Music]
you could you know you can have a
natural delivery but it could be
unstable it could actually be a script
um so that might not necessarily solve
this problem
so i'll move on to the second part of
the top um and so here you know this is
going back to
you know this kind of classical problem
in machine learning which is this
problem of exploration exploitation
right so this is kind of the usual
picture that that we're used to in
seeing in in multi-armed bandits you
have you know an agent um interacting
with an environment and has to choose
between options in every round
and you know in in this case you know we
have
the the solution is is
the problem is really about ex you know
exploration exploitation trade-offs and
they're very well-known optimal
algorithms and there's not this
basically this setting has been looked
at to death right
but a real missing piece here is how do
you learn about your preferences if
you're competing for limited resources
with other strategic agents
and so that's kind of the question that
the underlying question that we're going
to look at in the context of matching
markets um and so in in this type of
problem now you
you know the need is really to design
algorithms that explore their options
exploit their knowledge about their
about the options but also kind of deal
with this competitive aspect of these
problems
so we're going to look at this as i
mentioned in the context of matching
markets so
i'll go through the protocol in a second
but
we're going to have agents that are in
matching markets and they don't know
their preferences over over the other
side of the market and agents have to
match with firms and when they match
with firms they'll receive noisy samples
of their utility of that match
and we're going to assume that firms
have known preferences over the agents
or at least known to themselves not not
to everyone else
so the product the kind of game where
the protocol is follows at each round an
agent will request to match with a
single firm
so here we have a market we have two
agents requesting firm one and then one
agent requesting firm three and then
these are all kind of the known
preferences of the firms
um
and if multiple agents ask for the same
firm only the firm's most preferred
agent will get that match and then
everyone else gets no feedback or they
get a collision
and then if agents are successfully
matched they get a sample of their
utility of that match
and so basically look at the question is
how should agents learn in these markets
and also how do we even benchmark
algorithms in these problems
so you know to enter this let's go back
to the full information case where all
the agents know their preferences over
the firms in this case a solution
is the deferred acceptance or gail shape
the algorithm
right so the gale shaped algorithm is as
follows at every at the first round each
agent requests we match their most
preferred firm
um
and so in this case agent one and agent
two get the match
and the other agent three and agent four
get collisions
and then at least subsequent round each
agent requests to be matched with their
most preferred firm on which they've
never collided
right and so in this case
agent three after for firm two agent
four asked for firm two by agent three
gets it and this just kind of keeps on
going
um so every agent kind of keeps on going
with this protocol and then you know you
end up with a match
so
you know gail shapley is a really really
nice algorithm it's been you know
analyzed very well in the economics
literature and it has some really nice
properties the first is that it's kind
of fully decentralized so agents make
their own decisions based only on their
own local information
it's communication and coordination free
so agents are actually not coordinating
or communicating their actions across
rounds with any other agent
it's partial information because agents
don't have to see who they're colliding
with or know the firm's preferences
and it's guaranteed to converge to a
stable match and a stable match here is
just
a match where no agent for impair you
know whether bend in their current match
for each other and be better off
i mean in fact it's guaranteed to
converge to that to the agent optimal
match in finite time
okay so
you know in in this line of work the
question that we ask is can we design
algorithms with all of these properties
where agents have to learn about their
preferences
and they just also have low regret with
respect to the stable match
or a a stable match um because they
might be small
so this problem has seen kind of a lot
of attention in recent years kind of
going back to 2005
where there was kind of more of an
empirical study and then more recently
some some more kind of theoretical
results
but oftentimes
assuming some kind of coordination or
full observation of the entire market
and so our problem was really can we
design simple decentralized algorithms
without observations of the market and
without coordination between agents
so um our approach to solving this is
really just to split up the two kind of
aspects of the problem the first problem
is really about learning your
preferences and so for that we're going
to use a stochastic band algorithm like
ucb or thomson sampling
and then to deal with that competitive
aspect we'll just use an adversarial
band over them
and that's going to be to deal with this
kind of competitive problem
and so the algorithm that we come up
with kind of looks like this at every
round
it's going to use a stochastic band
algorithm it's going to rank all um kind
of all of the firms according to their
indices and just choose
um the firm you know with the highest
gcb so far
that is going to feed that choice to an
adversarial band algorithm
and the adversarial band abu algorithm
is basically going to flip a coin and
then if the coin is heads you're going
to play that arm and if it stills um
you're going to remove that arm from the
set and just kind of keep on going
so a pretty kind of simple decision
making protocol
um
and this kind of keeps on going and then
if the if you know the set of firms
empty you could just kind of arbitrarily
choose one
and you know after you choose the arm if
you get a successful match you can
update your stochastic band algorithm
with the reward if you don't um the only
thing you update is is the adversarial
band algorithm
and the way you update this is just if
you
don't choose the arm um
if so basically if your coin is quint
flip its tails you'll just get a loss of
a half um
if you
collide you get a loss of one and if you
get a successful match you get a loss of
zero
so you know very simple kind of
setup
and you know something to point out here
is that again this is fully
decentralized um communication
coordination free and partial
information so we get kind of all the
properties that we want out of this
algorithm
and so if we assume the firms and agents
preferences satisfy some more structural
assumptions we can actually give finite
time regret balance
and so to get kind of the best finite
time regret bonds possible we actually
specialize the adversarial band
algorithm to something slightly more
sophisticated than x3 um but the actual
assumptions on the agent's preferences
and um and firm's preferences is
something called alpha reducibility for
which we need this definition of a fixed
pair
and so a fixed pair is just a for a pair
of agents and firms
which both prefer each other over
everyone else in the market
and then alpha reducible market is just
uh it's just a market where every
sub-market has a fixed pair and so
what's nice here is that it guarantees
uniqueness of a stable match and
examples of this could just be kind of
serial dictatorship where every
where one side has all the same
preferences or something like that
and so as i mentioned we have to
specialize this adversarial band
algorithm and the way we do that is
actually by using some recent really
nice results by heiping and some of his
collaborators and sebastian bubeck on
path length regret bans um which is
basically just doing kind of mirror
descent with it with a different kind of
regularizing
um and so you you know there's a lot of
notation here but basically you just do
a step of mere descent at every step
um
and what we can show is that each
agent's
regret in these markets is basically
going to be logarithmic
so if every agent uses ucb or thomson
sampling to choose the arms
um and that you know mirror descent
algorithm with that log barrier
regularizer
as the adversarial band algorithm
then they're guaranteed that their
regret with respect to the stable match
will grow kind of logarithmically over
over the gap squared
and you know that's kind of the optimal
rate that we look for in bandit problems
but what's interesting is that this is
even optimal in the case where there's
no competition so somehow in these
markets logarithmic regret
is possible even when you're competing
and kind of even with this kind of full
banded feedback
um so
i guess i have some time for for some
numerical experiments um so basically
what we do here is we just have five
agents
seven firms and the firms have fixed
preferences and then every agent just
randomly uses thompson's outlander ucb
and they all use that
um that mirror descent um
regularize uh that mirror design
algorithm for the adversarial band
algorithm and then the i guess the light
blue behind is the stable match and you
can just see that you know it kind of
quickly kind of converges to a stable
match um here and then you can see over
here that the regret you know is kind of
logarithmic
okay um
thanks
um so you know in this part of the talk
i talked about how we could design a
coordination-free decentralized
algorithm for matching alert while
learning
um and what's interesting is exploration
exploitation um and on top of it you
know this this kind of competitive
aspect can actually be done by only
while only incurring logarithmic regret
which is you know optimal even in the
kind of stochastic bandit regime
um and so you know i presented both of
these works today um and if you have any
questions i'd be happy to chat so thanks
thanks a lot that was a great check
[Music]
let's see are there any questions
oh yes
what happens if the firms also don't
know their preferences and they're
learning them what they say yeah that's
uh that's usually work that's going to
be much harder um you i guess it could
work if you know they're
learning over time i think that might
not break it too much
um but we haven't really considered it
yet so i don't know what would happen
there okay thank you thanks
it's like noah has a question
some of these policy gradient methods um
if your game is like a coordination game
or rather this has like some potential
game structure
do you think that uh it would converge
yeah i mean if it's a potential game
it'll converge oh is that is that is
that obvious
isn't it
i in my mind if you have a potential
game things will converge kind of by
definition
right because if you have
like we know the better response out
with them but like it's not clear that
policy grading will converge like i
think that's
markup games is a paper that does that
yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if it didn't
that would be my intuition because it
doesn't zero some games um
and so at least in potential games my
intuition would be that all the nash
equilibria will at least be stable
um or at least like attracting locally
so you wouldn't have this problem that i
that i talked about um and then the
question is just showing that that will
hold globally
and my intuition would be that that
would hold just by the potential game
structure
um because there's some work by i think
catching again um where you again got
global convergence in zero sum games
um showing that the set of stabilizing
policies is invariant and in potential
games i think that would happen as well
um because no player would have an
incentive to push the dynamics you know
into instability so
i think combining those two would maybe
give it to you but that's a good
question um
might not be totally straightforward
yeah
and in this example what happens if the
agents are reviewing their preferences
strategically
so and this one yeah yeah here the
underlying assumption was that everyone
kind of used one of these classes of
algorithms um if you have one player
that you know wants to
be particularly
um
actually i mean in in in this market
they have no incentive to not use this
algorithm
because they actually can't do better
for themselves
by by doing something else
unless they they knew their stable match
they could get kind of no regret with
respect to their stable match
but and i'm pretty sure that in this
case they have no incentive to act
strategically actually
i mean uh if a coalition of them kind of
acted strategically then then they could
obviously do better but individuals have
no no incentive to do something else
i would never expect that
you may not want to if you're like the
second like a2 you may not want to rank
the firm firm one for instance first
because it's going to be taken by the
agent one
oh yeah but but these are kind of like
their innate preferences they can't
choose them
but okay okay
um so yeah i mean i guess if you have
like a kind of an adversarial bandit
type of problem where you have
players who can you know maybe choose
their preferences arbitrarily to mess
people up
because yeah they could have innate
preference but they could choose to
reveal preferences that are not their
innate preference but something that
maximize their reward yeah um but in
that case i think they would still be
worse off
than if they just played this algorithm
or know better off at least okay yeah
because they would they would compared
to their innate preferences they would
be doing worse
um and so the the reason why is because
if they were always choosing
um a better firm
than they were getting that than their
stable match then that firm actually
belongs to someone who's more preferred
by them
so that person actually just has kind of
full control over what would be
happening there
were there any more questions
all right why don't we stop it there uh
let's thank eric again thank you cool
we'll just have a quick little break and
then we'll come back at 3 15 for the
last talk of the day which is a video